hey guys it's been a while since i've
just done a video
sitting down talking to you and
answering some of your questions
especially questions related to my
career outside of youtube it's quite
funny because when i was in university i
shared a lot
of my experience learning game
developments
and my aspirations for what i wanted
beyond university
and now two years have passed
maybe no just over two years jesus
i haven't actually been talking to you
about where that journey has led me
i will explain more at the end of the
video why that is
but i decided that today should be the
day
that i break that cycle and i talk to
you
about where i am now how i got my job
in the games industry because i managed
to do it i love this to be a creative
platform
for me but at the same time i also want
it to be
an inspirational platform for you to
give you
insight into how to reach your own
dreams
and if i can share my own journey and it
can help you
that's what this channel is all about so
let's dig into some of your questions
first of all is a person called dom on
instagram d
dot nrg92 and they asked me a
bunch of questions but i think it'd be a
good starting place what kind of
education did you
have for your job what did you study so
i studied computer games arts which
actually isn't what i'm doing in the
games industry
but it allowed me the time the freedom
the knowledge to understand
what i enjoyed within the industry
itself
i thought i would enjoy the art aspect
of it more but i didn't i enjoyed design
i enjoyed prototyping so even though
maybe you're doing a course that you
realize halfway through
oh i don't want to be this
if you're still getting a chance to dip
your toes into that field
and make games don't worry too much
people aren't going to look at your
degree and say well you're applying for
this job but i see that your degree
is in art as long as you can back it up
with some
something in your portfolio after
university i did carry on
with our third year game making it as
good as i could be so i could use that
uh for a portfolio piece and they also
asked how quickly
after education did you land your first
job and i
was extremely lucky i managed to land uh
a job i think it was four or five months
oh wait no
yeah i think it was around about six
months actually because it started just
after christmas
and i finished university in the summer
i got rejected quite a few times and
quite a few times i didn't even hear
back from job applications
it's okay it happens just keep going for
it
you'll find something they also asked in
general
are there any wise words or advice about
getting
into the industry hi
okay so how long have you been working
in the game i will say what
helped me to get into the industry was
definitely
going to gaming events which i know is
extremely hard now
however there are online events there
are things
on zoom and all these types of stuff
that you can actually get involved with
and discord channels and just trying to
communicate with people who are in the
industry or
even who are indie developers gaining
those people who are already in the
field that you want to work in
is extremely helpful a lot of the times
it really is
being in the right place at the right
time and knowing the right people
i was lucky i went to egx and i remember
i
actually filmed a couple of videos
interviewing
people in the industry i don't think
this led to me getting the job
but just the fact that i already had
interviewed people in the in the
industry um
meant that a few people in the industry
were getting to know my face
so perhaps it helped me in the interview
process i don't know for sure
do not give up i got rejected quite a
few times and it took
me a day to make and send out each
application because i wanted to make it
personalized to the job that i was
applying for
so i would make sure that my cover
letter said things about the company
that i was applying for i explained why
i wanted to work with them
as well as why i thought i'd be a good
fit for the role
you really want to let the company know
that this isn't just a copy and paste
application you are actually
enthusiastic about the job
it made things a lot harder is a lot of
energy
to apply for jobs in that way but it
worked i really i really believe it
worked okay let's let's answer some
questions from other people now other
people
oh my gosh this is a great question and
why didn't i open with this one
virtual turtle games asks what do you do
at your current job and how do you like
it so far
i am a associate technical designer
which i did not even know existed until
i got this job there are so many
different niches of game design and it's
really hard to even know
[Music]
all the different types that exist
because i'm pretty sure
there's just new ones being made up in
studios and that's because
games are extremely unique games need
different
specialisms because of their certain
styles their
genres you might want mission designers
you might
need narrative designers um
but technical designers i would say are
always actually needed but they just do
slightly different things
in each studio which is the same in any
game design case
but what i do i like to explain it as
bridging the gap between
programming and game design itself
i can look at a feature within a game
and know what is needed to get that to
work
performantly but also to keep to the
designer's
vision so i can prototype things
but i also can keep in mind how
the game is set up technologically i've
got to have a really good understanding
of the structure of the game and
how it's put together via the code
that doesn't mean that i do code because
i actually don't um
i visual script but that's not the same
as
going in dim c plus plus but i gotta
understand how it's all put together so
that when
people have their ideas that they want
to put into the game
i can think technically okay what is
available for us
how can this become a new part of the
game
is it going to affect anything is it
going to have
negative impact on performance how
many different disciplines need to be
involved
in that new thing i have to kind of just
i guess be on top of everything if i can
and it's a real challenge but i love it
you know me i like to wear a lot of
different hats i like to
dip my toes into many different fields
and
this design role especially the
technical design role
gives me that exactly because it's not
just about being creative and coming up
with ideas
it's about turning those ideas into
something tangible
and something that works in the overall
vision of the game
and works performantly and nicely
and cleanly i
actually really like it turns out i'm
quite a logical thinker so
it's a nice role for me i do enjoy it
carlos rodriguez how do you keep track
on a game day project
i would think you used some tool like
trello and also
when do you know the game is finished it
seems to me that even though we have a
scope
there are some things art related that
could always be improved no no not just
art related
there are some things in every single
discipline that could be improved
i luckily i'm not a producer way
so if you're working in a big
studio um you'll have producers that
keep on top of
all of that kind of stuff but from what
i know from when i made perfection
anyway
i did take up the role of producer then
and a lot of it was
spreadsheets and having
small deadlines for different aspects of
the game
each small job was allocated to a
different person in the team
making sure no one was too overloaded
with work
checking in regularly with your team
seeing
if they are on track and if they're not
seeing what you can do to help them get
on track it's not
about getting annoyed that someone isn't
meeting their deadlines
sometimes these things happen especially
if you're working
in games working in the video game
industry you're usually
learning all the time trying to
understand new systems
uh new parts of the game engine that
you're using
you can severely underestimate or
overestimate sometimes so these things
happen
but yeah trello boards were good when i
was doing perfection
honestly the spreadsheet just kept me
sane just having a spreadsheet that you
could always refer to
but luckily in my day-to-day job i don't
have to worry about that i have my tasks
assigned to me i know how much time
i've got to do them i usually wake up in
the morning
and i write myself a to-do list for that
day
and i try and get everything on that
to-do list done
for that day oh and how do you know a
game is finished
i thought i was done with that question
but no it's the hardest part of it
you don't and this is not just for games
this is with anything creative
you don't you're never finished with
anything that you create
it's never going to be as good as what
you imagined it being in your head
and if you stick to that way of thinking
you're always going to be disappointed
one thing that i heard i think it was
from like john and hank green
they said always aim for 80 instead of
100
and i still stick by that i think that's
great advice because
if you always strive for 100 you're
never going to reach it and
a finished project is so much better
than a perfect project that never sees
the light of day
and once you get one project done then
you've learned so much
during that process and you can create a
new project
with that new knowledge in mind and
probably make something even better set
yourself a deadline
and make sure that the main pillars of
your projects are there does it
run from start to finish does it have
the
the feel that you want does it convey
the message that you want are there
any major aspects that i'm missing just
make sure that you have
had as many people play test as possible
to find any major bugs and major
breakages
and as long as you're happy with it
you'll know
whether you think it's finished or not
and the good thing about a game
that is different to doing a video or
anything like that
is that you can still keep updating it
once you've launched it you can have
patches and updates don't hate me for
saying that but
it's true we don't try to we don't try
to release unfinished things
just sometimes they're not as good as we
want them to be but we want you to play
them okay okay i'm sorry cyberpunk okay
okay so that's all the questions that i
had regarding my day-to-day job
i can't go into it in detail because the
game that i'm working on
hasn't been announced yet so i can't
talk about that i can say that my
experience in the industry so far has
been an extremely positive one
i am surrounded by people who hold me up
uh they're also the biggest
kids ever which i absolutely adore
as soon as i got my job i i was pinching
myself that i could be sat with people
in a pub talking about video games
uh in a very enthusiastic way it's so
freaking cool to know that you can talk
about
games and playing and get paid for it
it just doesn't seem real and you're
kind of like uh am i
cheating life right now i'm not gonna
say it's all good there are certain
aspects that
are pretty hard um
i mean the job itself is really hard
there's so much to learn
it's extremely overwhelming sometimes
luckily the people that i work with
they're all
very happy to learn and also teach
so if you have questions they will
answer them actually that is my biggest
advice just always ask questions
i ask questions in wreck all the time
and sometimes i do
probably come across as a little bit dim
or i think that i do anyway but i
ask regardless of how i feel regardless
of if i feel
dumb or whatever because at the end of
the day
i want to know i'm here to learn as well
as to work
always always always ask questions stay
curious don't
beat yourself up but saying that is very
hard it's
it's hard not to have major imposter
syndrome
in this industry it's a fantasy job um
maybe you will feel like you don't
deserve to be here
and i know i i have been struggling with
that for for quite a while since i got
here
should i actually be here uh i don't
know c
plus maybe i'm not smart enough um
you're talking to all these really
intelligent people but at the end of the
day
i'm still here i'm doing something right
and
i've been scared to talk about it on
youtube because honestly i'm scared that
if i give any
design tips or any kind of how to's
in the game industry i'll say something
wrong and then i'll be
called out as a fraud
it's literally just the imposter
syndrome that's been keeping me away so
i've been
sharing different types of videos with
you and you're my creations
which will never stop i will always make
music videos and things like that
but i do want to share my knowledge with
you
in the video game industry i can't share
things that i'm doing on my day-to-day
job
but making a cinematic and unreal engine
stuff like that if i could show you what
i'm learning about
unreal engine or even just the design
process and the mindset of a
game designer and how i'm learning that
it could be good it's just i've just
been so scared
yeah that's stupid it's all in my head
and i'm having
a wonderful time i'm very lucky i'm very
lucky
and if i could help other people i
really want to
so if you'd like me to go into any more
detail
on to how i got my job
perhaps how i lay out my cv cover letter
tutorials on game design or anything
like that
let me know as well if you're not really
that interested
then that's fine too i can keep this
just a creative
creative channel but anyway yeah that's
my rant and that's why i haven't done
any
q and a's it's like i did i didn't want
to jinx it i didn't want to make a video
and say okay
i'm in the industry and then suddenly
lose my job or something
and then be like oh oops but yeah i
think i'm safe enough
after two years to say yeah and
i feel more confident to be able to
share
what i've learned with you all so i hope
you enjoy that i'm just gonna answer
some quick questions that
weren't necessarily about my day-to-day
job
every westmoreland corner said as
someone whose head is always bursting
with ideas how do you keep
track of all your plans and imaginings
without losing focus of what you're
working on in the present
that i struggle with so much and maybe i
should do a whole
video on that but what i do is i have a
discord
and i actually have channels that are
privated just for me
and i write down all of my ideas podcast
ideas
music ideas video ideas game ideas
i just make sure they're all in one
place every month
i go onto google calendar and i plan out
my month and i might not stick to it i
mean usually honestly i don't
stick to it but it makes me realize okay
what do i want to achieve this month
and then i make a rough plan of how i'm
going to achieve that
and that's how i stay in the present on
what i'm working on because it's there
in my calendar i'm getting
notifications about it and i know that i
have to finish this project
to then be able to move on to future
projects
discipline learn it learn to discipline
ashley edwards says what keeps you
motivated
and how do you combat periods where you
don't feel motivated at all
and this is a very good question
especially in 2020 honestly i think this
year has
given us time to get to know ourselves
to reflect on
what makes us happy what doesn't what we
miss what we don't so much miss
for some people they've been thriving
and good on them but i think a lot of
people have
have felt pretty unmotivated this year
because of the amount of worrying
they've been doing and
that makes us all very tired very
understandable and i definitely have
gone through that as well this year
so what did i do to combat periods where
i didn't feel motivated
i i didn't do anything
i found things that i loved and i found
things that
that rejuvenated my sense of wonder
and my sense of creativity without even
really meaning to
if you try too hard then you'll just
stay and burn out
so i think just being able to say okay
this year has been crap or you know i'm
not
in a good mood if you don't even need to
have a reason sometimes
i am not in a good mood for no reason
but the more that i fight that and i say
no i don't want to be in a bad mood i
want to be
motivated i want to be happy and blah
blah blah the less
i will become happy and become motivated
if i say to myself okay i acknowledge
i am in this headspace uh i need rest or
i just need to be kind to myself right
now i come
out of it so much quicker so
for me personally it was witcher 3
and reading books and going for more
walks
and doing nothing creative while i
worked
that out in myself i love witcher 3. i
think that
made my whole year so much better i love
liking
anyway let's carry on
[Music]
okay i have some questions about my
music but i think perhaps that should be
a separate q a so also comment down
below do you want a music
q a i feel like whenever i sit down and
do talkie videos it just goes off topic
i'm sorry sorry
jonathan says where do you see yourself
in five years time
professionally i'd like to see what sort
of work and hobby related projects
you'd like to achieve in that time i'm
not very good at planning
for the future i mean personally on a
personal level i'd love to have my own
place that uh that is purely mine
that would be a step in the right
direction but work related
i'd love to move towards doing something
more
narrative focused i'd love to have
learnt c
plus by then hopefully i know i'm never
going to be an amazing programmer
because personally that's not where my
interests lie
however i understand i need to
i need to know programming to create the
kind of interactive experiences that
that i want to make and yeah i'd love to
find a role
that incorporates more narrative in it i
would love to be like a
narrative technical designer if that is
a thing i'd love to be
someone who thinks about the way that
the world
interacts with the player and the player
might interact with the world so not
necessarily writing
but more the small things that tell a
story
within the universe without even having
to have dialogue
or written word there's got to be
something like that in the games
industry like some
someone who builds upon the world in a
technical
way that fits with the narrative and the
game feel
do you know do you know what i mean i
think it'd be called a narrative
tech designer i think that's the thing i
don't know and as for hobby related
projects
i i still want to see if i can update
perfection because
i have learned so much and i am
very ashamed with the performance of
that game
i remember i put a lot of code
in the update which now
i am mortified and i would never do
anything
in tick or update unless it's absolutely
necessary so
oh i have a lot of music that i need to
record professionally i'd love to make
another
ep or album i have some podcasts
that i want to create i want to start
writing again
get back into that narrative mindset
which will help with my career goal
and eventually i'd love to make a sequel
to perfection
perhaps not perfection too but a game
that
thinks in the same way as perfection a
game
that lands on social interpretations
of ourselves our sense of self-worth
i love the fact the game got
conversation started
and i'd love to make more games like
that but it's just finding the time
alongside a full-time job
that's the only issue that i have
hopefully that has
filled you in a bit more i've tried to
fill you in on two years of my life and
in maybe a half an hour video
so thank you so much for watching all of
this if you've watched till the end i
really appreciate you
and i hope you feel like you know me a
bit better now i also just want to say
thank you so much to everyone who's been
joining me
on my thursday evening live streams it
means so much to me
talking about motivation i sometimes do
lose motivation and i can't get a video
up every week and it does frustrate me
but i know
that i have my weekly live stream to
look forward to
and it's always so fun to play horror
games
to just sing songs and just chat with
you guys live
like you shove my neck my back
look it really does put a smile on my
face no matter what the week has brought
especially
in 2020 and i hope it's managed to
give you a little bit of fun time
during the week as well those live
streams will carry on in the new year
and if you would like me to go into
any more detail into what i've spoken
about here today
or if you'd like to see more about my
music
projects instead of my game dev stuff
then do let me know in the comments down
below
have a lovely day or evening and a
brilliant christmas
if i don't see you before oh wait um if
you don't
celebrate christmas then have a
brilliant happy
wonderful holiday i don't know i know
times are different i know
it's strange whatever i still hope you
have a great
a great day anyway and i will see you
when i see you
thanks again for all the questions i
keep saying thanks because i've
forgotten how to end
videos okay bye have a lovely everything
bye bye bye
is
[Music]
glory strip from